MODERATOR: Now i'm going to give you a remote control.
MODERATOR: And now you should be able to start reading.
P2: The tasks okay so.
MODERATOR: If you want to read it out loud maybe makes it easier.
P2: Okay section submit the query inputs on the left.
P2: Here explore the resulting linked environmental data that appear after keeping submissions you submit button God.
MODERATOR: that's tasks to you should start in task, one which starts with.
P2: Oh sorry i'm reading what i'm reading what's on your screen.
P2: But you want me to go back to my.
MODERATOR: or sorry yes.
P2: Okay, fair enough Okay, and so that's 20 what you see on the screen two panels that amendment read the text within home tab main are allowed and all sorts of your choosing budget right clicking dropping it.
P2: In a new tab explore data source of a choice choose an open in a new tab once you feel yourself whether it comes from click to.
P2: Open up to visualize the density of data points within the equations of interest will be done when you mentioned a few of the otherwise that have data points available okay back to zoom a home i'm going home, and so I have to.
P2: find a data set of interest, so I think i'm just going to open this Oh, I see no data, whether no and.
P2: So there was something that right clicking i'll have to go back sorry not having two screens going to slow this down a bit and.
P2: read the text known to man, I think I read already explored a data source of your choosing by right clicking and opening is in a new tab okay i'll try again as a data set of your choosing.
P2: And there are data sources temporal Is that what you mean data temple units chase visualization I don't know if those are what you mean by data sets of my choosing.
P2: and David Robinson government funding sources and so sorry i'll have to go back here again, but I suspect that there's a mismatch between what i'm reading here.
P2: In task one and, once you figure this out the data comes from now so.
P2: Right clicking so explore add data source of your choosing by right clicking audacious source, yes I have it now okay sorry I didn't read properly first time.
P2: So a data source and their traditional sources temporary minutes and spatial gentle obligation, or I don't know if you mean these ones, so I think i'll try these ones.
P2: Now that doesn't right click of course my most might not right click just because yours does.
MODERATOR: Controlling the screen.
P2: I have.
P2: A I have a mouse moving around here on the screen, I thought it was working.
P2: It says i'm you are controlling it, go to the screen.
MODERATOR: Okay, can you move it because I don't see it moving.
P2: I can.
MODERATOR: Do yes, yes perfect perfect sorry.
P2: Ah, now it's now it's saving differently right i'm getting a but I don't know what right clicking does okay so i'm going to try, whether.
P2: Open link in new tab open Lincoln new window open link and private window and I guess, we could open a new tab.
P2: Will I be able to see that.
P2: yeah okay.
P2: So.
P2: Okay, and that's not your fault, I understand that that's because of the lag.
P2: Okay, and allow don't allow that's you don't know want me to do i'm going to say don't flop Okay, so we can go in here, and I can look in this region and find data and find more data.
P2: And and.
P2: Okay, and when I get to hear that's the solid gap, I can find blah blah blah.
P2: 30 are averages okay.
P2: whoo whoo.
P2: Okay, not sure he wanted me to go there and.
MODERATOR: know it just for you to understand where the data comes from that.
yeah.
P2: it's coming from Aaron okay.
P2: We won't accept all cookies I think I knew that anyway alright so i'm going to abandon I gotta go back to here for now and pollution well I love it well, you probably don't miss out Okay, so let me go back to the task.
P2: This would be easier if we were doing.
P2: In a place where you could set it up for me.
P2: With multiple screens Okay, so I understood open map visual identity response locations, you will be done when you mention a few of the noi set of data points available, I said Sally gap so you'll be large but that right okay.
P2: submit a query using input options available the creator on the left, most panel, while you're selecting the query options, please explain about the specific choice to make.
P2: let's make choices new ones will become available, just like once you reach the employees click submit button once which will only be very valuable to be selected we don't want new tab name qr is displayed in main panel up the dashboard please only submit one query okay.
MODERATOR: I don't want to interrupt you, but you mean the last part of the first task.
Oh.
P2: You were.
P2: Okay, once you feel you've answered the critical critical open map oh to visualize data points of did I not opening them up soon okay all right.
P2: Well yeah this one try.
P2: Okay, I thought you wanted me to look at the.
P2: Come on, open them up oh there it is.
P2: Okay.
P2: Okay, and so this is where you wanted me to look at the data, the density of data points okay.
P2: find a way to get closer.
P2: clicking on this map isn't doing anything which I was hoping.
P2: there's a plus button, there are see now.
P2: Okay, and.
P2: The number of data points Okay, so in County West me that we have to population pollution records one weather record.
P2: And Okay, and in Dublin, we have 27 pollution records and three weather records okay.
P2: The data points density i'm not sure if I know what that means, but am 27 plus three is 30 that's what's going on there okay.
P2: And if I click back here yeah okay that makes sense sorry yep I did miss that task and Okay, so I need to go back one oh no it's it just opened them up OK, so now i'm going to go and do I think I had finished reading the query.
P2: yeah so my most decides changes in mind about whether it wants to be impacting on your screen and off everybody, we are OK query so.
P2: I read, most of the thing no I read all the way to the bottom, on that one okay so and i'm interested in a rare disease, perhaps Okay, the only disease in here is like a basket I just fair enough.
P2: And i'm interested in different flares high probability flares possible flares are no fillers let's say high probability flares because I know there aren't very many flowers.
P2: So, and now what I don't know from this is where the data includes high probability and above or just high probability only and which is something that might be worth being able to understand better and then I have.
P2: and
P2: you've given me some information about what's.
P2: available, so I presume that somebody in Carlo huddle high probability flair on the 21st of September 2017.
P2: Okay, but I think you told me that you only 320 20 days deep data but that's okay all right, and I could look at more of these if I wanted to.
P2: have lots of Dublin ones okay fair enough and i'm going to select Dublin because there's loads of cases there might want to select multiple more than one not sure if that's possible, let me have a look sounds like Dublin anyway.
P2: A workaholic oriented get all violent, but let me stick with Dublin date range i'm going to.
P2: pick first June.
P2: Hello.
P2: whoops and first of June that worked okay and i'll go to the end of 2020 you told me already had a French 20s and the writer.
P2: 31st of December is.
P2: not available.
P2: Okay 30th of December okay and data sources, whether or pollution, I guess i'll go for pollution is quite a lot of pollution records in Dublin and and.
P2: Okay, so do I want hourly pollution records daily blues records monthly.
P2: Publication records, I guess, on wondering when I read that is our average over the month.
P2: And how are these the hopper even mean to get our pollution record by the hour, but a lot of data so i'll go with daily for now and and.
P2: spatial temporal aggregation I know what that means, but I guess, not everybody in the world would and and I go to the mean the map domain, or should I go with the Max because that's kind of interesting.
P2: And i'll submission.
P2: hit submit I think yeah good.
P2: Okay, so some data has come back and nine different.
P2: windows servers and looks to me like.
P2: yep there we go Okay, I was having some trouble getting into scroll.
P2: Okay, and alright so and here's the output data, and I think I was who's that task on a hit submit and we go back to the tasks.
P2: And my acrobat reader and so you'll be done when a new job Thank you want to space maintenance okay did that looks great okay explore the q1 tab in order to the template underneath there are two buttons or have you interpretation that you see click both buttons on top.
P2: and open query input summary and open color table description commenting on a useless and clarity explanations okay.
P2: then read the text in the data sub tab and talk to the interpretation variables and sell background color is red and blue data.
P2: You can set the columns you want to display with the toggle columns and not that you can scroll vertically horizontally and use the page arrows.
P2: To check meditation jquery by scrolling you were done when you figure sufficient exports table Okay, so I got explore what are the two things.
P2: clipboard buttons at the top, read the text in the data sub tab and talk to the interpretation variables and circular backgrounds okay so back to zoom.
P2: And so, this button, or just not clicking on other ago and.
P2: is telling me that I, this is what the date, this is the query data issue basically.
P2: I don't know why it has the word open in front of me that's not clear to me what that means, but query input summary maybe makes more sense so that's me could think about.
P2: So I picked out of I started with high probability and Dublin an iPad pollution data and as a second page of this apparently or had to do with the data, presumably and.
P2: it's not going to the second page but that's probably a delay problem like imagine if I did, it will be telling me the date range or PICs on prepared.
P2: Okay sliding over the place, oh yeah and the other things I picked cool OK, and then.
P2: Again I don't grow the word open means there but that's Okay, and if there is no mystery 95% should be between.
P2: minus two and two that's course and it will be quite if the value is greater than to be read and it's less than minus two would be okay that makes sense of the word, three colors in the stuff when I look at it Okay, I wonder, can I close these again our water just scrolled away.
P2: Okay.
P2: Okay, so I did that job and then obviously the data table, which I think is this one here and yeah data.
P2: Top full name verbs with units appear when hovering over the headings of the data table oh cool that's good.
P2: cook.
P2: For opposite okay Emily please refer to the data source links in the home tab Wu Tang claims button allows you to select becomes interesting to export data Okay, so I could decide that i'm interested in and.
P2: or we're not doing talking, we were just exploring I think at this stage, and you didn't ask me to toggle things yeah as far as I remember, so we've got some data or maybe you did, let me go back and check what you asked me to do.
P2: And so, set called did you want to display oh yeah Okay, and then you can score too hard on the news page arms Okay, and I haven't found any red or blue.
P2: Values everything's whites of ours for like a job, but I could go to different pages okay so okay there's a red one is you know, and so the so to.
P2: On the second of June and 2020 was out to the range cool as enough and PM 2.5 was above the range should have been a on the sixth of know on the 16th of that month cool okay so i'm going to just trying so if I toggle so toggling if I click that button that one goes away.
P2: And i'll get rid of some of these other ones, because there's too many going across the screen okay i'm not talking right place there.
P2: I want to keep someone's i've heard of before i've heard that one I know what seo is carbon monoxide very interesting and.
P2: I feel like okay so there's.
P2: The can tell if they're more columns and my scraper to.
P2: guess the right because they were getting wider where they, as I was.
P2: As I was.
P2: Getting rid of them okay so i've got the day the month the year I know the year so i'm wondering to hide that now because that's not much used to it.
P2: So now God month day PM to 1pm 25 nitrogen dioxide and so toolkit all looks fine and I have.
P2: Lots of values and it's got to be loads because I.
P2: Because I selected a long period of time, so there's another company blues yeah should be nice to see some blues but we'll keep going Okay, I can scroll up and down the page give nicer with a big screen and.
P2: move up and down.
P2: Okay, so there's a pink one we'd I wasn't anticipating a pink value and.
P2: Because yeah I don't know what the right value means but that's good maybe I clicked there tonight or problems.
P2: Okay, fair enough, I didn't notice it's a bit slow be so hard workouts going on there's also a funny just where I wanted to push here there's a blue you probably can't see it but there's a blue.
MODERATOR: Account that's for.
P2: Monitoring our head.
MODERATOR: that's what it's for some admin stuff like.
P2: hey so it's just making it very hard to find the little arrow that I need, which is the.
P2: same for you okay i'm just gonna keep going and see what when any blues.
P2: And then I got to give up.
P2: I know I have to scroll a little bit slow anyway, I can tell that if I wanted to see every value of these things for all the dates that.
P2: I am now I toggle of side obviously did it i'd made a mistake here is I didn't want to change the offerings.
P2: Oh no I didn't want to that either now haha if I want to bring a call him back, how do I do that Oh, here we go good, so I want to come down to come back okay what I told him I do is to check because I seem to have I messed up the ordering.
P2: When I wasn't paying attention yeah and funny this one I can't.
P2: I can't see the one to change the month ordering so I don't know what does this digital enterprise problem.
P2: Air Okay, and of course that's Why would it would be interesting, why don't I do this now if because i'm interesting finding blue ones, if I did this.
P2: A it's going from our from low to high hopes crazy and and i'm on page six So if I were to go back to the first page.
P2: or low PM to VI VI us but they're not blue Okay, I was thinking, my friend blue one know blues there that's even when the blue ones here.
P2: and start going in order, I wanted to go in, yes oops so what i've learned here now is that the lowest no to in that six month period was on the seventh of know the fifth of July that's possibly conceivably useful sure Mrs water supply outside as well.
P2: And the 18th of July was the lowest so July was a good month.
P2: For pollution all right Okay, and I, if I can find the button to get to the end, I think this one's.
P2: Quite reaches Okay, I think i've done a really good job of exploring the data task list okay and.
P2: Vertical harder and you don't want to pet i've explored the table okay explore the other tabs beside the data tab all three plots sanctuaries box on polar polar interactive with features for different purposes, please use those huge problem mentioned users in each one i'm sorry.
P2: We don't when you export for the interactive features for each of the three tabs okay.
P2: So here's the question.
P2: yeah when I go off to my to find the document when I come back it's not all.
P2: immediately and controlling your screen but i'm getting there now Okay, so I saw this earlier it here time series so now, this is where you need to sign a statistician rather than a computer scientist like okay that looks like something I can understand.
P2: And the things went up and down.
P2: it's including all of the variables, not just the ones that I shared churchill's or a lot okay and but perhaps I might want to remove some of them at some point anyway i'd be like to think.
P2: i'd like to think that July would look a little lower than some of the others, since we sold off when I was fiddling around and but there was a high honor that pipe him 25 was in.
P2: late June fair enough, and things are not so good, the beginning of August okay now apparently I can toggle things, so let me see.
P2: can remove that one possibly.
P2: A muted, on the other thing, and I can move this one, presumably so we'll get the similar view as I hadn't the other one, these are the three things I was interested in earlier.
P2: Okay, and it's funny how what starts so two was high the beginning of November, as well as the beginning of August, with no good reason for that.
P2: And what the hell happened to PM 25 on that anyway, probably related to whether some of those things Okay, so I talked to those things that offers a little toggle so in here zoom out zoom okay zoom however single and multiple times and download was PNG so zoom.
P2: zoom.
P2: not sure how to zoom but.
P2: I might just be more patient or look into this sorry Okay, so now we're looking at.
P2: yeah okay just go to look at this end of November, whether these very high red ones and yep Okay, and some of those are very small and but show data set on show closed state of hover.
P2: i'm not sure whether that means oh yes Okay, yes, when i'm hovering on getting some information about their colo It makes sense okay and download as a PNG Am I gonna bother doing that and you've told me a can I guess it's one of these buttons here.
P2: Anyway, okay go ahead and click the variable to dislike to Double Click certainly i've done sort of selecting or I can do, select only if you want me to.
P2: Do who go.
P2: Okay, all right and range that I did that already okay cool so now i'm going to go to box plots.
P2: and
P2: So you asked me if I don't be a useful but, of course, since i'm not really somebody who does this kind of analysis or not it'll tell you much about you, so what I can tell you whether I can use us, which is, I think what you really aren't.
P2: Okay box plots Okay, so I do that recently about box plots, but I think we might do the same move some of these and.
P2: So I was kind of expecting to find the things down here that I use last time to get rid of ones that I didn't want and but that's okay and.
P2: And that's a little PM 25 so I might have to zoom let me see.
P2: Okay, and what that's done is hidden stuff smart daisy.
P2: Yes.
P2: Okay, I can't see the boss now so i'll just go back go back to where I was before.
P2: Okay they're all between two and minus two okay so i've explained why couldn't see them so i'm gonna try that one more time.
P2: Oh yeah because they're all centered around zero so it would be better if, when you did, that the.
P2: I can't make I can't make it damn.
MODERATOR: there's a button, that is, which is the Cross next magnifying glass.
P2: wasn't obvious to me Okay, and so now looking at I was trying to go to Gal stick to it, oh.
P2: Hello.
P2: Can you go back down there.
P2: Okay, and can I can know what's going to pan sideways so one thing that be might be interested to do is to be removed some of these things, probably doesn't say that I can you upload your zoom hover.
P2: hand and download okay So what did I do, I did hover hover.
P2: yeah upper lower no to Max did it up okay so there's more variability in.
P2: No to than in some of these other ones, this one's wasn't a much variability at all.
P2: And now I got the planning to work sideways.
P2: No, I don't think account so i'm going to.
P2: Come back over here turn off the planning, but um yeah okay.
P2: Some of these problems is the delay.
P2: Okay, so CEO to CEO doesn't very much.
P2: You know, to varies quite a bit old tree where is more and.
P2: I can't get the thing to pounce on it all right that'll do for that one okay pull up I don't think I even know where to pull up clauses so that'll be interesting Oh yes, that makes sense for windows about direction but I didn't do wind so there's nothing to see here.
P2: That makes sense perfect and and if I did, I would be able to zoom hover pan okay so.
P2: I think I finished that task.
P2: yeah okay.
P2: So create to nuclear so i'll try to a weather query with some wind and the sun after you submit it and follow the same services and step two.
P2: you'll see crust q2 q3 Now you can prepare them period of time okay read the Texans top a certain number of groups, you wish to make it very complicated and then click on.
P2: click to generate groups, a new inputs PR group will appear underneath okay.
P2: So i'm not sure if i'm going to order group is when we work with work away arrange a quiz into groups are you guys into groups and click on click to plot groups.
P2: Now, new sub have appeared three different visualizations please mentioned are these fuzzy on a certain amount of step three okay so we'll see what I can do.
P2: Right, so another query so to do anything comparative and useful, it would be clever to take the same patients that seems to me, and the same time period but get different different.
P2: Different data so i'm going to try and do that so.
P2: I presume on into clicking in here okay Hello i'm controlling your screen parenting okay so good, to go thank of US gliders i'm going to go with high probability i'm going to.
P2: Try and there we go got go Dublin i'm going to go with the same data rate date range but i'm going to put in whether.
P2: whoops whether or not pollution, and given that you told me that I was comparing.
P2: Not pollution Okay, and I guess I should so do daily and and I was getting the Max of the pollution variables across a day but sure why not get the mean of the weather pollution, the weather.
P2: data across the days Okay, and I got hit submit now unless you scream at me that i've done something stupid.
P2: So there we go.
P2: And I would.
P2: Think much more trauma Nice and soft something's happening cool.
P2: Okay, nine pages so that's it yeah because there's the same number of days, as it was before might have made my life easier if i'd gone with a smaller time time period but nevermind okay so.
P2: Okay, so okay.
P2: Comparative I think that's what i'm supposed to do next, this is query to just kind of a very quick locals We have lots and lots of variables and some of them are not very interesting, like the ones that are not brightly colored.
P2: what's our home.
P2: Relative humidity presumably and and so on, and that sun is more sun than usual, and this is less relative humidity.
P2: than usual okay alright, so I can see why it makes sense, this collaborative thing now okay comparative so we'll just review some of this discussion, and we compared by specific compared by specific variable okay so that's oh yeah so I could put and day and.
MODERATOR: you combine these queries in the owner with.
MODERATOR: The previous to have the same task because you missed.
MODERATOR: Can you should query two times so you have three queries to compare.
P2: Ah, OK.
P2: OK, and I just couldn't read this for a second right because you can squeeze in groups and multiple segments 2% increase in okay paired by specific variable okay i'm not sure how we're gonna do our groups Okay, so I have to make another one and.
P2: and
P2: Okay, so i'm suddenly wondering it So these are.
P2: These.
P2: yeah i'm not i'm certainly wondering what relevance to uncover and all this has to that's right all i'm getting here is.
P2: weather and pollution days deep data for every day for six months in Dublin and it's got nothing to do and seems to me with whether somebody gosh.
P2: A vasculitis or not or had a high probability of flair or not i'm not sure i'm certainly not sure what that's all doing and in here and that's an issue because.
P2: I can compare whether pollution in other places I don't need to come here and you think, having listened to you for a long time in avert meetings that have some idea what that's doing but I.
P2: I don't because, as far as I can tell each record that i've been looking at is one day.
P2: And a day so i'm getting six months of of records, so I have no idea how that relates to a person with or without an ankle vasculitis okay anyway.
P2: persist here now what could I could conceivably want to compare and I can't think what i'm able to compare the weather in one settlements, with the weather and different settlements, maybe and.
P2: I can't I can't narrow down to particular data sources okay daily monthly yearly Max Max suppose I could put in a Max instead for this one.
P2: Just.
P2: Not helps no at all and I can't see any reason to change any of this because I don't understand at all what this is doing.
P2: What I do these things are doing for me on I don't serve so from my perspective, all that stuff above there is not relevant because i'm basically getting.
P2: Whether inclusion data for Dublin for this for this for this range of dates Okay, and this time I got to go with whether again, but I got to get the Max whether I go into submission.
P2: submission.
P2: yeah.
P2: Okay, and so there are some yellow blue blue lomax I use for something here for some some variable I didn't find any blues here come on.
P2: scroll up scroll down, please.
P2: Okay, too much of a lag and oops it's the wind direction, which is okay and that's different from all the kinds of ones okay and low relative relative humidity again in early June.
P2: Okay, so now i've done that now i've gone back to compare thing I think i'm a little bit out of my depth here now, this stage.
P2: So these are the number of groups, you wish to compare select which queries you want to group and explore each environment variable with the different plots.
P2: Chris Gruber computing the mean per unit of time in the time queries or group but computer mean per unit of time, as I mean as long and by capturing the values in the box and just.
P2: forgot where, despite his building okay i'm serious thought as a limitation combined queries with different time units okay.
P2: And query data previously submission this session can be compared by specific variable you can combine these queries into groups with the multiple selection inputs.
P2: To potentially increase the signal to noise ratio you combine these queries into groups of the most likely was.
P2: OK so i'm out of my depth here right i'm really don't understand why we want to do anything in groups because i'm not a i'm not a researcher and but I go to groups so that I have some chance to maybe keep tabs of what's going on.
P2: and
P2: I am going to so sorry Okay, and then i'm going to say group one, so, if I remember correctly grew query one was a pollution one.
P2: i'm going to compare that with he.
P2: With some other.
P2: Things you, all I can do so i'm going to do generation groups.
P2: On either that already, I think.
P2: You said it was a bit okay.
P2: select variables to compare groups elect to compare groups Okay, so I don't have those variables in my two things might be more sensible to do.
P2: To group, but there are both the same my data story matters and MINS okay so Max is no means an axis, so I won't have any variable costs to accept days and I don't know if you've got days in your last operating on the boys.
P2: Look.
P2: For msl.
P2: When speed when direction some.
P2: I guess I could me see what i'm doing I could compare I could check I could maybe maybe that's what i'm supposed to do see if this PM 25.
P2: Okay.
P2: So, as I said, i'm a bit lost so i'm going to try and i'm going to try and change this so that so that I can compare.
P2: The Max.
P2: have some pollution variable to the meanest some pollution variable if I think to this true now probably get it i'm going to i'm going to make this say am.
P2: I going to make this say q3 I think.
P2: So i'm going to do group ones q3 so I don't I still, as I say, don't tell the group is and.
P2: And now I have at least gosh and so time series or, should I do time series now because I kind of understand what i'm doing and i'm going to look at.
P2: select a variable to compare the groups, so I can look at the, if I understand what's going on here correctly, I could take the temperature here.
P2: And the red one is the mean and the blue one is the Max so i'm able to see that can compare the main in the Max of the values for a temperature.
P2: On all my months from my months so that makes some sense, and so I suppose I don't really and I don't know what the Group word means and all of this, but.
P2: Okay, I feel like there's something that's going on down there and I can't get to it, for some reason at the bottom of the plot and.
P2: yeah I saw I don't know what this part here is doing.
P2: But that's okay don't have to and.
P2: A but this makes some sense to me I think i've interpreted correctly right, so the red one is the is essentially what I my means and the blue one is my is my Max is over that period of time, if I had.
P2: No, because I I don't know how I would have.
P2: I would have thought it might be an interesting to over that time period to plot say whether the temperature and PM 25 or.
P2: Something and something, but I don't know how I could have done that, given the way the groups were offered to me here.
P2: Because I was only allowed to pick one variable to compare groups, if I understood correctly, I could try, one more time, I suppose, and now you can only pick one variable like certain say which crazy want to group.
P2: Six for each environment variable would different eat explore each environment variable with the different plots Okay, so I could have a look at a box talk now, but I think this is going to be much less interesting.
P2: Oh sorry because variable true let's stick with temper.
P2: Okay, so what the hell is this telling me and.
P2: The total set of Max temperatures.
P2: across my six months.
P2: looks like this, and this the box style, and this is the means.
P2: OK so again i'm able to compare my temperature maximum is my main jobs but I might be able to like be able to to see something to work and take two variables and see if there's a correlation or something going on between the two of them.
P2: Okay, I think i've done work supposed to do here as best I can do and go back and look at the task.
P2: Okay, so I did my best on that okay now she's one of the queries to export you can go to that tab click the export bond ratios diligence to find opens up.
P2: And trying on the left hand side panel and click on the download zip with all data tables to download all the all the greats mission session as as it for you, be done went understanding, where the stage is stored okay.
P2: OK and limp okay over here and perhaps I wasn't paying enough attention because I can't go to go now we need to click.
P2: download.
P2: Okay, so this seems to be all queries I thought you'd mentioned being able to do some queries and not algorithm just read this again.
P2: and choose one of the quiz to export and go to the top okay click the export button OK, and then zip download Okay, so I didn't do that I went to the second task for us to go to the first chance for us to I can q1.
P2: q2 and so i've done q1 The only question now is whether this is the bottom that you want me to download is there.
P2: Is there any other workplace or concept know so it's going to do this.
P2: Okay.
P2: So you put in the local phone named up five I can't get a job thanks OK so i'm assuming that I would find that, if this is my computer that will work Okay, and I guess.
P2: I guess that i've done all the query so I have to go back here and see if I can work this out again.
P2: So choose one of the queries to export you want to talk to, and then go to that tab click the export button okay I didn't find the export but that's where my problem is too large so pick one query.
P2: Contact tab open query open description, to the da okay that's all about what's going on.
P2: Data time series box toss polar plus or maybe the data tab that might be Part A higher so can we make sense.
MODERATOR: Because you were the loading into my computer I just press cancel.
MODERATOR: Okay.
P2: OK so that's how I would export that data that makes sense and then this one exported all the data does okay so seven says my overall impressions and.
P2: Okay, and so my overall impressions is it's useful in terms of ways, looking at environmental variables and a possibly I misunderstood something about the grouping, so I wasn't able to do.
P2: What would seem to me to be useful to compare one variable against another one across a time series, or maybe multiple variables across a time series.
P2: And, and that may be misunderstanding your mind and and I also as i've explained don't understand the how what relationship, there is between the.
P2: vasculitis high probability of flare and the days that i'm looking at I basically as far as I can make out with looking at data.
P2: For all the dates in question now maybe if I picked a different county where there were fewer cases.
P2: But I don't see how that's going to be different if I if I made the query I made I would expect to be getting weather variables and or pollution variables means or max's or whatever, I chose.
P2: For all the days in that time period which is seems to be completely independent of whether somebody had a flare or not so that's I think I explained those to come come and complications.
P2: Throughout the interview so and he it was it was I was a what was able to do everything I was supposed to do, I can't help, I was able to do everything was supposed to do.
P2: And, but the things that I was able to do were reasonably easy to do some of the buttons took a little while to find that, because some are very small, given the way in which we were carrying out this.
P2: exercise which wasn't ideal on my laptop screen and and, and so my yeah so my overall experience was a little bit frustrating, I suppose, because of the, as I say, the setup and the delays.
P2: A and a little bit confusing because of the two things i'm confused, but I don't understand groups very well and I don't understand the relationship between the disease and the flares and whatever, so I think i've done as much as I can do by summarizing probably my experience.
yeah.
MODERATOR: and well, so the recording now.
Okay.